university of pennsylvania okay so i
heard more than one person said to me
that this talk sounds interesting but i
don't understand the abstract at all so
hopefully i will explain it I'll explain
what this title means by the end of the
talk you will know what it is but you
have to be a little bit patient this is
kind of like an anthology of short
stories where sometimes the title of the
whole anthology is one of the stories
and so this is the second story but the
first story is not that dissimilar okay
so we'll see what that is so a real-time
decision making that's the that's the
title of the workshop most of the talks
we've heard our decision-making by
algorithms so this talk is not about
decision-making by algorithms but it's
in making about algorithms and i'll
explain what that means there are two
versions to theoretical models i'll
present about decision-making about
algorithms I think these are pretty
decent models but they're a little bit
the good theoretical framework but a
little bit Hollow because they're not
that many great examples yet so that's a
perfect time to to think about these
models and do some good work so there's
a lot to be done here okay so let me
start with the first occasion to this
way so many of you have encountered this
kind of setting where you're driving on
a highway make your passenger in a car
and you you're planning to take 55
northbound mallory third straight and
here you see the sign maybe the highway
department need to invent more signs to
help you in these situations maybe they
need to say you know something like
uncertainty just ahead or tough
decisions ahead but but the situation
you're in is that you're you're in the
passenger seat you know that this exit
is supposed to come in a certain amount
of time you got to decide what to do how
to find you don't know this area very
well you got to decide what I'd find the
alternative and you have a few
heuristics you can think of one is to
pull out your smartphone and try to plan
our new route but that requires you to
enter some very complicated input that
says avoid this exit and find me some
other route and you don't quite know how
to do that it might take you a little
while
now there's a turn on your radio and
stick to a favorite AM station and wait
for the traffic report to cycle in the
third thing is to scan your radio dial
and try to find a station that's showing
traffic at the moment so there's a three
different heuristics you could use and
you don't know which one to use okay so
so this is one example of the situation
sorry that's not an option sorry okay so
so the first part of the talk tries to
model the situation in one hour consider
the situation one theoretical way and
this is talk on this is a party called
timers so I'll explain what they are so
so it's basically if you want to turn a
heuristic into a good algorithm what's
the difference between heuristic an
algorithm we all know that in our field
very well so typically when you have a
heuristic to make it an algorithm you
want to prove correctness and you want
to prove time bounce and so what if we
cannot do that which happens a lot we
can try to do empirical demonstrations
that the heuristic works well this is
not a preferred mode in our field
somehow but I think it's worth trying
some cases the other sort of fashionable
thing to do is to make the heuristic
modify its up and call it machine
learning but I'm not going to talk about
that am I going to talk about that so
the other the point of the timers the
section is to try to establish establish
these properties on the fly you don't
prove something in the worst case about
the heuristic but try to establish
either correctness or in this case time
bounds on the fly as you get the input
specific to the actual input that's the
real time aspect of that there's the
thing that's happening in real time is
at the input is arriving you have a here
is a few heuristics in mind maybe or one
let's say and you have to decide how
will this heuristic perform on this
input so in the example that I gave up
the driving scenario the passenger is
the heuristic in a way or the passenger
using the phone as a heuristic or the
passenger using the radio dial is a
heuristic and and the input that's
arriving is this information you're
getting on the freeway that says this
exit is closed or whatever that's the in
that's and you have to decide if you as
a heuristic and handle this input fast
or which of your heuristics can handle
the input fast okay so what is the so if
a program for correctness there's a
well-established sort of formalism
called program checkers and here is how
that works so I'm going to sort of try
to draw inspiration from this so I'll
just briefly explain how checkers work
so you have a heuristic it takes an
input I and produces an output oh you
have a notion of what it means for the
heuristic to function correctly that's
independent the heuristic itself and
what a checker does this heuristic is
supposed to compute some function f so
this is a checker that checks that the
heuristic is computing F it also looks
at the input and looks at the output
produced by the heuristic it is allowed
to talk to the heuristic ask the
heuristic other questions about other
inputs and it's supposed to have these
following properties if the heuristic is
buggy on this particular input then we
want the checker which is randomized to
output buggy with very high probability
if the heuristic is correct on all
inputs then we want the checker to say
yes it's correct with high probability
you don't want to say raise a false
alarm but there's a gap here meaning if
the heuristic is buggy on some other
input the checker may or may not detect
that bug right now it's only required to
detect the bug that's happening right
now if it is happening and if not it's
free to say whatever it wants and
roughly speaking whim on the checker to
be more efficient than the heuristic
because it's not what's the point of
running the checker we might as well run
a correct program in the first place the
checker has to be fast okay so how do we
translate this into the timing world so
try to come up with a similar idea for
run running time so you have a heuristic
that's a it's known to be correct let's
say that you're not worrying about the
correctness problem only about the
timing problem so th of X is the
notation I'm going to use for the time
taken by heuristic H on on input X
you're th of X you're given a deadline
function that is the amount of time you
want to allow the heuristic to run on
inputs of length n Saudi of n is the
amount of time the heuristic has to run
on inputs of length n and we say that E
is a timer for a heuristic with a
deadline function this was the original
definition that is on any input X if the
timer say stop that means the heuristic
is going to take more than the deadline
amount of time so this is kind of a
timer going maybe in the opposite
direction to what you want to talk about
that in a minute so if the heuristic is
going to take a long time this timer
will tell it to stop sometimes not
always the definition is very loose and
and then what happened see so and the
other thing is that we want so that
means okay sorry what this means is that
if a heuristic is going to run fast on
some input the timer will never stop the
heuristic on that input so it'll only
stop the heuristic on some inputs where
the heuristic does take a long time and
we want to hear the timer to be useful
in some sense and what does it mean to
be useful we want to say that if there's
any input that causes the heuristic to
take more than the deadline amount of
time then there's some input at least on
which the timer says stop I mean you can
imagine a timer that just never say stop
right and that's fairly useless and this
is forcing the timer to say stop at
least on some input where the heuristic
takes a long time and the last thing we
might we will want is that the the timer
itself runs in time less than the
deadline function can i'll explain why i
mean it's obvious but i'll say why in a
minute are there any questions on the
definition so again it's sort of the
soundness in a sense for here is that
the heuristic if it takes less than the
deadline time then you let it run for
sure and then the the liveness or the
usefulness of maybe something like that
is that if it takes long then you will
stop it at least some of the time
and uh and then it runs fast okay so
timers in some cases are very easy to
define sometimes it's a hidden parameter
of the input that determines how long
the algorithm takes if you can quickly
evaluate this parameter and then compute
how long it would take and it's less
than the deadline you can let it run in
those kids or if it takes more than that
deadline then you can stop it that's one
way to design timers if we can somehow
prove and this is a trivial cases if you
can somehow prove that the heuristic
does work within time d of n you can say
always go because then that's clearly
correct and of course the reason we ask
the timer shouldn't take more than the
event time is that if you allow it to
take d f n time you can just simulate H
for the event time and then if it stops
you stop and if it doesn't stop you just
say stop at that point anyway right so
so those are some simple examples okay
so there are many variants of timers
I'll give some examples in a minute but
there are many variants of timers so you
can have a strong timer which should say
whenever they say whenever the heuristic
will finish within the deadline it
should say go but whenever for at least
a constant fraction of the inputs on
which the heuristic will take more than
the deadline it should say stop not just
one input but for a constant fraction if
you can that's a strong timer and then a
complete timer is somehow able to
exactly get a sense of how long the
heuristic will take and says you know it
says stop if and only if the heuristic
will take more than the line so it's
very hard to imagine designing complete
timers and it's very easy by
diagonalization standard techniques to
construct heuristics for which there are
no timers forget complete time is even
just timers so that's so in general the
problem is undecidable so the game here
is to say can we design timers for
particular heuristics that we have
and here is 6mb randomized to third
probabilistic timers as well so there's
a probability that you say stop and go
and there's all do the right things and
the last last kind of variant that's may
be interesting is to have a gap between
so you want the the heuristic the timer
to say it go whenever the heuristic
takes less than the deadline time and
you want it to say stop whenever it
takes a factor more than the deadline
time so there's a gap between the
deadline for go and a deadline and a
point at which you should say stop okay
so there's there's other variants like
that it's me give you one or two small
examples so one example say bubble sort
everyone's favorite sorting algorithm so
let's say that you're given a deadline
function that is some constant times n
squared sine squared over 100 or
something like that and you want to know
if bubble sort which is going to take so
you want you give it an input array and
you want to run bubble sort if it's
going to stop with an N squared over 100
and stop it if it's going to take more
than some N squared times some other
constant something so we know that
bubble sort is well understood we know
that the number of exchanges performed
by bubble sort is proportional to the
number of inversions in the array so a
very trivial timer here is to wrap pick
random elements back random pairs of
elements and see they represent an
inversion so an inversion by the way is
two indices I and J such that X I is
greater than x j so they're opposite
order of what they should be so you pick
random pairs of indices and if they are
an inversion you count the fraction of
times you get an inversion and you get
an estimate of the expected number of
inversions and therefore you can know if
bubble sort is going to take a really
long time or about the deadline or not
and then then then stop it if you have
to you can actually make this this is a
order one randomized timer yeah then
it's complete you can show that up to a
certain factor it'll catch all the all
the things that will take more than some
amount of time and and will let run all
the things that will take less than a
certain amount of time but you can also
get an order n deter
mystic timer by doing something a little
bit clever a little bit more complicated
Knuth gives a very detailed analysis of
bubble sort and the inversions and how
you can estimate inversions in various
ways and if you use one of those
formulas it turns out that you can get
an order n timer deterministically for
this as well so I won't go into that
okay so generalizing this idea there's a
nice relationship which is not full not
very much explore at all between a sort
of timer design and property testing and
spot checking so so what is property
testing for those of you who haven't
heard this property testing is a really
neat sub linear procedure which takes
some kind of combinatorial object and
the goal is to determine whether that
save a let me give you a concrete
example so you're given a graph and the
property you're interested in is is the
graph bipartite let's say so this
property can be tested which means what
what that means is that you can take
some constant tactical is a constant
time procedure which if the graph is
truly bipartite will say yes this is
bipartite with certainty and if the
graph is far from being bipartite and by
far we mean that a exelon n squared
edges have to be removed before the
graph can be made bipartite it's a good
number of edges have to be removed
before the graph can be made bipartite
then this procedure will say not
bipartite as well so this is property
testing an example so in the general
general sort of paradigm which allows
you to test certain properties by saying
this is this object have this property
or is it far from having this property
and there is the version of property
tester is called tolerant property
testers it's tolerant property tolerant
testers where you want to pass the
objects that maybe not don't have the
property but within a certain distance
of within a small distance of having the
property epsilon 1 and reject the
objects which are very far from having
the property epsilon 2 so you have this
notion of property testing and we can
there are many properties that you can
tolerantly test in basically constant
time and so the idea
would be if you could define a property
that is captured by exactly those inputs
for which a heuristic is fast then a
property testing framework would allow
you to design a timer for for those
statistics and many sorting algorithms
tabs mean so basically inserts sort
works faster the input is close to
sorted that that is the property that
can be tested so whether whether certain
input is close to sort it can be tested
very efficiently so that means that you
can design a timer for insert sort so
those are some examples so beyond
property testing and sorting just as
another example this is not a complete
timer it's almost again these are all
just puzzles at the moment there there's
me to develop this kind of theory for
more real real problems but so Euclid's
GCD algorithm on n bit numbers right so
this everyone remembers this algorithm
you take two numbers a and B you divide
the smaller number into this larger
number and replace the larger number but
the remainder until you get a zero and
then you stop so this is the Euclid's
algorithm right so we know that on n bit
numbers Euclid's algorithm runs in order
n times is a very nice analysis that
runs an order n time but what if we have
a deadline function that is a k which is
less than n how can you tell given two
inputs whether you close up when will
finish in less than K iterations where K
is some smaller number and this is not a
complete timer but so X is an error this
is actually if it's not only ever so oh
no this is correct this way it's correct
so
maybe I'll say it like if x and y are of
this form then we can we can prove that
Euclid's algorithm takes at least K
iterations so it is correct the way it's
written this is the con con the
contrapositive it's written there so
these are figure I'm sorry these are
Fibonacci numbers and it's not hard to
see when it's fairly trivial to see why
because whenever they divide why is a
smaller number here if you divide X by Y
you're going to get a quotient of one
and when you subtract out what they're
for you take X minus y and you'll get FK
minus 3c + FK minus 4 D and the thing
will propagate until you get you know k
rounds of these things so at least four
pairs which are of this form we can be
sure that you're going to take at least
K steps so we could we could solve this
this pair of simultaneous equations for
c and d and and if you get a solution
then you know you should stop you should
stop this algorithm because it's going
to take too long given the deadline
function that's an example of a
non-trivial timer so it doesn't always
stop inputs where it takes long yeah
just a general question not specific
this is all you have a deadline k and
you're spending some of that time yeah
you're anticipating my second that's
that's a great segue and I think I'm
just about ready to move on but yes
you're that I'm not going to mix the two
but you're asking me to take what I'm
going to say next and put it into this
context but yeah that's so it's a fair
point yeah but I don't know how to do
what you want actually in this case yeah
okay so some other problems with timers
so some iterative algorithms for example
finding fixed points you can you can
sometimes get a bound on the number of
iterations a lower bound on the number
of iterations based on the derivative of
the function for which you're finding
the fixed point or something like that
or some other you know numerical
analysis algorithms you have some lower
bounds for convergence and so you can
design timers by quickly analyzing these
lower bound conditions enumeration
algorithms where the goal is to
enumerates all the maximum matchings in
a graph or something like that
you can get a timer by you know counting
or approximately counting the objects
you want to enumerate and that will tell
you at least how long you will take and
there's also you can prove I mean you
can get timers for problems that are in
RP and just click orp if one of the
sides is much faster than the other so I
want to say much about that okay so now
I'll get to the second part of the talk
and so that's the thing about timers the
second part is the really again the
title of the talk as well this is work
done by my student at that time and
Amanda McGregor but it's very relevant
to it's very similar to this timers
model as well okay so slightly different
highway situation because everybody was
talking about traffic i was trying to
find examples from traffic to motivate
my talk so a slightly different highway
situation you saw that you're going for
a job interview you've got 45 minutes to
get there but you've cut things close
and you don't quite know how to go you
could spend a little bit of time you
know trying to find you know this is
ways for example you go two ways and
spend some time trying to figure out the
route and you may not be happy with the
rule and you spend a little more time
going to google maps to find another
route and so you could spend a fair a
bit of time computing but that eats into
the time you have to get there okay so
this is a static is that the previous
motivating example I gave us a more
dynamic thing you're on the freeway and
you got to have a deadline you gotta
decide what to do this is like you have
time to do something but the time you
spend planning gives you less time to
execute the plan that that's what it
means to say when computing time this
time lost okay so so so and then I guess
you have to choose how many different
maps you're going to go to and so on so
i'll give you one concrete example so so
a scheduling problem so the problem is
you're given an instance with end jobs i
need to schedule on one processor and
the difference here is that the time to
schedule is part of the time you have so
you have a total time t at x 0 you're
told what the end jobs are various
parameters of the end jobs you got to
decide what to do what the schedule is
and then execute the schedule on this
processor okay so
and so what is the characteristic of the
job each job has a release time or I a
night job it has a length L I and
there's a value for performing the job
that's the amount of pay off you get
performing their job and you can only
perform a job after its release okay so
so now what if the time to compute is
part of the time T and we want to
compare our solutions in this model to
the static version where you offline
version where you could plan your
schedule beforehand and use all of the
time T to execute the schedule so if you
want to compare what we can do in this
kind of model versus the best you can do
if you had time beforehand to prepare
for the schedule and of course in order
to have a chance at all you cannot let a
job be very long suppose the highest
value job is a job that takes exactly T
steps okay and then every other job is
miniscule and gives you a very little
payoff if you do any time planning then
you're going to not be able to perform
that high value job whereas the offline
schedule is going to perform the
high-value job and you're hopelessly
lost right so to avoid that let's assume
that no job is is God you know it takes
more than t / k for some k greater than
one so maybe some real k greater than
one the key will show up in various
bouncers should remember what that k is
it's a bound on the link to the largest
job so there's a standard dynamic
programming version which is pseudo
polynomial for this problem the pseudo
polynomial version is to say the optimal
schedule that schedules all jobs from I
to n what happened to my cell right I
lost all the text okay one second maybe
I should just advance that okay so suit
up I'm sorry so the sooner polynomial
algorithm so uses a recurrence below
sort jobs increasing order of release
time and then let so so we're letting
this di t be the best reward from jobs I
through n in the last T seconds so it's
a standard and then you can compute a
recurrence for di t as the maximum over
main sights is just simple
recurrence but just it's it's a maximum
of two different terms whether you use
job I or not okay so that's all to
remember so each di t can be computed it
with a max of two things and then let's
see so again eating computing the
recurrence eats into the time T
available for scheduling that's the
that's the model we have and just to
make the so if one of these times is
much smaller than the other the scales
are very different this problem is not
that interesting that is if the compute
time to compute the schedule is super
fast and the scheduled execution is very
long or vice versa then of course it
doesn't matter i mean you can just do
what you would have done so you got to
have them be roughly about the same
amount of time and so in order to
achieve that lets say that computing one
step of the record one value in the
recurrence take some chow / n time okay
so that computing every di t for one
value of t you fix the value of T
computing all and di tease takes time so
that's the constant amount of time it
takes to compute one value of T and let
a towel is less than one just term yeah
to compute the optimal schedule 42
seconds you need Towe of t2 time ok so
that's the model ok this happened again
and again ok let's see I just put it all
in oops okay so you're going to compute
for t1 which is tau T over 1 plus tau
time and run 40 t2 which is T over 1
plus Delta so basically however long
you're going to run the schedule you
need tau times that time just find the
schedule for that length of time so if
you solve this out you find that the
best thing to do if you're going to use
dynamic programming all the way is to
use this much compute time and this much
sket actual schedule running time and
you can prove that that achieves the
Prophet again compared to the offline
version it achieves the prophet of that
much ok so this is like saying that
you're going to use set on doing dynamic
programming you're just finding you up
to
scheduled for as long as you can and
then running the dynamic programming for
the length the rest of the time so for
example if style is a half what you're
going to say is that I'm going to spend
time computing 40 over three of the time
and run the dynamic programming for 2t
over three of the time that's what our
equals a half would tell you but but
maybe that's not the best thing to do
and so mouse again okay so that may not
be the best thing to do and one thing
that actually beats that bound is the
following algorithm don't run dynamic
programming all the way but use it only
up to the point where the time that
you've computed for and the time that
you've scheduled for together add up to
something less than T so you give
yourself a little bit of room and do one
job greedily in that little bit of room
that you've left yourself and the greedy
part takes time to compute and then you
have still t / k time to do that one job
and that's enough for any job so so
basically you stop short with a dynamic
program you don't actually scheduled at
the whole interval and then leave
yourself room to do one job greedily and
you can prove that actually achieves a
better ratio so that's where that ratio
is better than the previous ratio and if
you look at the details you'll see
exactly in the in the lower parameters
but I mean that's just a proof of
concept but in fact you there's
something to be done here it's a kind of
a meta algorithm that's mixing the right
amount of dynamic programming with the
right out of the greedy and this is one
particular mix that does slightly better
but maybe there are other mixes so could
we do even better with a different mix
of greedy and DP I don't know so this is
again just the first example in this
area that are probably other problems to
consider as well it feels extremely true
to life that you do careful planning but
it's too much hassle to plan all the
ways yeah right yeah but again it may be
there's the more sophisticated thing to
do I don't know at what point we give up
and just do something crazy but maybe
you should do it earlier yeah
kozma or how long it takes to computer
schedule so other that asks you how it's
your total along the day right the this
order be said that i made a primitive
how long it takes to solve one step of
the recurrence and i said that takes
about tau over n steps for some constant
tau so that n recurrence that recursive
values together can be computed in tau
time so just just as a way of getting
the scales to balance exactly so yeah so
basically right you can figure out the
correct optimal schedule for one more
time instant in time tau more steps and
tau maybe a half or something less than
one yeah okay so actually when I talked
to dick about this he said what about
branch and bound so I thought about it I
have me I don't have any results here
but so another sort of problem we could
consider is the kind of a branch and
bound setting where let's say that each
node in a branch-and-bound tree takes a
constant time to evaluate so at each
node you get lower and upper bounds on
the best solution in some way of
capturing the uncertainty about the
actual solution possible in the sub tree
rooted there and descendants have less
uncertainty than ancestors as you go
down the tree you're more and more sure
about the exact time your solution will
take say you're finding a schedule the
optimum solution schedule which fits in
the remaining after the branch and bound
is done and so we need to find the
correct solution and we don't know
anything about how to do this ok so that
basically is all I had a half hour slot
in the afternoon size back plan for half
an hour so I guess I'm a little early
now yeah
it reminds me a little bit of one of the
things I mean talked about yesterday i
think it was a setting where you had a
distribution over arrivals some sense
and you spent like an epsilon amount of
time distribution right yeah yeah we
were just like yeah that's a good
question so he was talking about the
online matching problem with that kind
of you spend a little bit of time right
yeah looking at the distribution of the
boys that are going to arrive and then
plan your matching accordingly that's
the setting so here think so I mean this
is definitely a case but then okay so
what is the computing time here so while
you're watching the initial sample maybe
your your computing the distribution so
okay so i don't have it fits directly
because i want all the input to arrive
at time zero that's the model is you
have all the input arriving at time zero
you spend a little bit of time computing
and then you have to execute what you
have so the online version doesn't seem
to fit that well that's right yeah yeah
yeah there's a solution of epsilon
reading square design which is exactly
what I'm used to it yeah because our
refinements of this where you say that
instead of spending time to learn and
then executing a fixed of the rhythm so
maybe their variance here where instead
of spending the time initially you can I
see ya then you have to go to a model
where inputs that coming all the time
but right now I'm thinking of the model
with the inputs all arriving at the
beginning but maybe there are
interesting versions of this problem
where inputs keep arriving yeah I do I
don't know you added there's a lot to be
done here yeah there's a related flavor
of work the student where you use
computing time to decrease the variance
or learn some distributional information
about the running time of the job
perhaps afraid off between using time
for sort of being able to schedule
better which is I mean it's different
flavor it's interesting yeah and there's
a little bit like the first part of the
second point in the first part of the
second but like you have a deadline and
you want you spend some time figuring
out if you'll make the deadline and then
run it like what you are asking earlier
yeah yeah another example might be the
multi-armed bandit problem huh let's say
playing slot machines then you're trying
to find the slot machine that gives you
the best / step but you need to or maybe
choosing medical treatments okay yeah
something like that and at some point
you have to decide that you've done
enough sampling and you're just going to
stick with what right used to be the
best and then you think waited after you
might say that if the sampling is very
close race between two treatments then
you can predict that it wouldn't be it
would be pointless to do more sampling
you might
and go with one of them I see it's a
little bit louder like the secretory
problem like a stopping rule kinds of
things right i mean is a net of the same
flavor yeah yeah so baby comment what
happens if you have to play this game
repeatedly and and you know you don't
you don't need to succeed every single
time but most of the time to do it to
fall within your limits wait so you're
saying but in both cases are you saying
that the the effect of the Bandit is to
give you a length of required length of
time or is it a quality of treatment or
something I that's more two treatments
are indistinguishable in their
performances so far yeah I conclude that
the time of but the cost of
distinguishing them will be so great
that you may as well right yeah yeah
that is right okay and that's right so I
think that is an interesting direction
to explore it yeah I think it's so here
it's not liked it rating of computing
time but the cost of computing against
the cost the benefit you could derive
from a slightly better treatment so
that's so yeah yeah yeah so if you
discover that one mapping application
almost always is better than the other
maybe you should stop that's okay good
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but you know
that that's not really the case right
having is there are certain areas of the
world and setting geographies where one
mapping thing is going to be better than
the other that's what everyone said spit
yeah yes like we're talking about
reinforcement learning now yeah bunch of
heuristics right which is good and we
slept them into foreign basis for killer
learning and then we update your
decisions then there's a stopping rule
which I keep a lot of women right yeah
there you can formalize it all to the
Belvedere the change yeah yeah yeah
somehow there's a feeling that there the
exploration time is exogenous plore and
here it's like when you spend time
exploring you're losing the time to do
what you have to is is more endogenous
the time I guess yeah yeah yeah what
events of the application yeah yeah yeah
yeah there's also the baby there's some
family awesome right so you have a high
level planner in a low level executor
yeah you still and take more time to
plan we still will delay the start time
of your of the task right right yeah
yeah absolutely yeah especially in
control yeah especially if you replace
release times with deadlines that say
say you have deadlines for tasks to in
order to to get the reward that you're
going to get which is a common
scheduling variant then any time is
spent planning you're not going to meet
some deadlines so you're going to miss
some jobs deadlines and so on so there
there might be the difference there is
that you might actually do the planning
a little later you might do something
quickly now and then I don't know so
it's a little bit more complicated you
might mix in the scheduling with the
planning because you need to meet
deadlines so that's a different variant
ultimately you want to get the maximum
reward from the jobs you meet the
deadlines for or something like that
yeah yeah
so I my wife you go before the scheduled
any other is going to bring something
there what happens looking yeah why
don't we wait for 10-15 because they may
be like hammers yeah yeah okay so
shocked right now